françoise dolto donc qui par parenthèse
et est aussi la mère du chanteur carlos
ils avaient tous les deux d'ailleurs des
relations très proches
françoise dolto qui a marqué je vous le
disais tout à l'heure la psychanalyse
ces travaux faisait autorité sa fille
qui elle même a suivi ses traces a
expliqué alain labouze l'importance de
ces travaux écouter elle était
merveilleux c'était l'été elle était
bonne et est intelligente elle était
drôle mais était généreuse et est
toujours un travail dans sa tête
toujours à s'occuper des autres
même quand elle était très malade pour
ceux qui la connaissaient pas bien
qu'est ce qu'elle a apporté or je crois
tellement de choses que je suis bien
incapable de le dire surtout maintenant
je crois que elle elle a quand même
marqué un tournant dans l'histoire de la
façon dont on conçoit le psychisme des
gens et puis dans ton contre la place
des enfants le respect d'un fond je
crois que je crois que si elle si elle
voulait laisser un message c'était
respecter les enfants plus que aimé y
qui veut pas forcément dire grand chose
proxité surtout le mot respect récemment
elle s'était énervé à propos des
histoires des droits des enfants parce
qu'elle disait mais enfin on ne parle
pas des devoirs aussi on parle que des
droits mais il ya le devoir des
éducateurs des géniteurs
et puis si on parle à quelqu'un et ses
droits il faut toujours lui parler de
ses devoirs ya trois jours encore elle
écrivait une préface oui ça a été son
dernier plaisir pour justement parce que
c'était une préface pour une juge pour
enfants québécoise qui a une éthique
dans son abord des enfants qui est
merveilleuse et c'était très important
pour elle de soutenir ça parce qu'elle
était très très soucieux du sort des
enfants quand les adultes se disputent
autour d'eux